الباندا العملاق ايمي يعود الى الديار
برفقه صغيريه وصل ايمي الى موطنه في
مقاطعه بجنوب غرب الصين حيث سيقضي شهرا في
الحجر الصحي في قاعده ابحاث لتربيه
الباندا العملاقه قبل ايام من وصولهم عادت
باندا عملاقه اخرى اسمها التي ولدت في
اليابان عام 2017
بالهتاف والدموع هكذا ودع اليابانيون
الباندا الساحره
ليست بنده لطيفه فقط بل هي ساحره انها
جميله جدا لدرجه انك اذا رايتها مره واحده
فانك تريد رؤيتها مره اخرى لقد انشات
علاقات الصداقه هنا بفضلها انا متاكده من
انك ستكون محبوبه ايضا في الصين وامل ان
تستمر في خدمه الصداقه بين اليابان والصين
كان ينبغي ان ترسل الى الصين في عام 2021
لكن رحلتها ارجعت عده مرات بسبب القيود
التي كانت مفروضه على السفر بسبب رائحه
كورونا
تحظى هذه الحيوانات البيضاء والسوداء
بالشعبيه كبيره في كل انحاء العالم
وتقرضها الصين كجزء من برنامج دبلوماسيه
الباندا لتعزيز علاقاتها مع الدول
الاجنبيه